Hey there, Shankar here. Back in January 2017, we released an episode called Pettistills and Geateans. It explored an interesting paradox of human behavior, our love, hate relationship with people at the top of the social hierarchy. Why are we so drawn to the rich and powerful? And what is it that makes us so excited when they fall from their perch? So much has changed in the world since we worked on that episode. But as a long election season in the United States winds to a close, we found ourselves reflecting on this episode and what it says about the transience of power. We hope you enjoy. Welcome to Los Angeles, the celebrity capital of the world. It's a city that conjures palm-line boulevards,
大家好，我是香卡。早在2017年1月，我们发布过一期名为《Pettistills and Geateans》的节目。它探讨了一个关于人类行为的有趣悖论：我们对处于社会阶层顶端的人既爱又恨。为什么我们如此被富有和有权势的人吸引？又是什么让我们在他们从神坛跌落时如此兴奋？自从我们制作那期节目以来，世界发生了巨变。但随着美国漫长的选举季接近尾声，我们发现自己开始反思这期节目，以及它所揭示的权力的短暂性。希望你们喜欢。欢迎来到洛杉矶，世界的名流之都。这是一座让人联想起棕榈树成荫的大道、
sprawling mansions, luxury cars. At the center of all the glitz, Hollywood. Movie stars are the only ones here. Star gazers are drawn here too, like paperclips to a magnet. With the Musac blaring, a handful of people on a celebrity tour pure out there van, hoping to glimpse the homes of Elle's rich and famous. The guide points out Gwen Stefani's house, and a clump of bushes behind which she claims is Quentin Tarantino's home. She pulls up Nyakadi Perry's compound. Do I have any Katy Perry fans, Abort? Fine, your works. Okay, well here's her house.
鳞次栉比的豪宅和豪华汽车的城市。在所有浮华的中心，就是好莱坞。这里可不止有电影明星。追星族们也被吸引到这里，就像回形针遇到磁铁一样。伴随着播放的音乐，几个参加名人游览团的游客从面包车里涌出来，希望能瞥一眼那些富有和成名的明星的住所。导游指着格温·史蒂芬尼的房子，以及她声称是昆汀·塔伦蒂诺住所的一丛灌木。她把车开到凯蒂·佩里的宅邸前。“这里有凯蒂·佩里的粉丝吗？好吧，随便。总之，这是她的房子。”
Look up to your left and you'll see the awning, the red awning. You can't really see it's red there, but we are right beneath her house. She actually owns the entire corner here and look at her view. It's amazing, isn't it? One of the tour's most popular sites is the home of Kim Kardashian. Well, sort of. Kanye and Kim, they needed a house to have their friends over Tor's most popular site is the home of Kim Kardashian, while sort of. Kanye and Kim needed a house to have their friends over and on the left hand side this
“抬头往左看，你们会看到遮阳篷，红色的遮阳篷。虽然从这儿看不太清是不是红色的，但我们就位于她房子正下方。她其实买下了这里的整个转角，看看她的视野。太棒了，不是吗？”游览中最受欢迎的景点之一是金·卡戴珊的家。好吧，算是吧。坎耶和金，他们需要一个房子来招待朋友。游览中最受欢迎的景点是金·卡戴珊的家，虽然算是吧。坎耶和金需要一个房子来招待朋友，而左手边这栋
is the house they use rented for 12,000 a month. There's somebody right behind it so I can't stop. I'm sorry about that, but that is the house right there. Has its own little swimming pool. Boy, they had some big parties too. Tor's like this are big business. Andrew Imordino helps manage the tour company called Star Track. He says not just Americans, but people from all over the world sign up for these tours. And they kind of want to just get that little feel, that little taste of what
就是他们租来用每个月12,000美元的房子。后面正有人在，所以我不能停车。非常抱歉，但那栋房子就在那儿。它有自己的小游泳池。天哪，他们也办过一些盛大的派对。像这样的游览是一门大生意。安德鲁·伊莫迪诺协助管理着一家名为“星光追踪”的游览公司。他说，不仅是美国人，来自世界各地的人都会报名参加这些游览。他们只是想获得那种小小的感觉，一种小小的体验，去看看
it's like to, you know, see the celebrities's homes and do all the crazy stuff that you see in the magazines and the television. But it's more than just wanting a taste of celebrity culture. The glitz and glamour, the swimming pools, the manicured grounds, the storied homes, humans hunger for a chance to pure into and fantasize about lives of luxury and extravagance. This extends to our political leaders too. We adore the pomp of state dinners and inaugural balls. Ladies and gentlemen, the President of the United States, Canada, Cleveland, and Bruce Wayne, America, Canada, Cleveland. We dream of what it must be like when presidents make life and death decisions for a nation. No matter how long it may take us to overcome this premeditated invasion, the American people in their righteous might will win through to absolute victory. We fantasize about what it must mean to be fabulously rich and powerful.
名人们的住所，并去做你在杂志和电视上看到的那些疯狂的事情。但这不仅仅是想体验一下名人文化。浮华与魅力、游泳池、修剪整齐的庭院、充满传奇色彩的住宅，人类渴望有机会窥探并幻想奢华与奢侈的生活。这也延伸到了我们的政治领袖身上。我们崇拜国宴和就职舞会的盛况。“女士们先生们，美国总统……”我们梦想着当总统为一个国家做出生死抉择时会是什么样子。“无论我们要花多长时间来克服这场蓄意的入侵，美国人民及其正义的力量都将赢得绝对的胜利。”我们幻想成为极其富有和有权势的人会是什么感觉。
Words can't describe how beautiful it was. Everything you saw was breathtaking. And we got to meet his girlfriend, Melania, who was amazing as well. Hi, hi, I'm Melania. College adulation, adoration, idolization. Humans are prone to suck up to the rich and powerful. But this turns out to be only one side of our psychology. On the other side, it's something entirely different. Many of us hate the rich because they are rich. We want to see the powerful topple from their pedestals.
“言语无法形容它是多么美丽。你看到的一切都叹为观止。我们还见到了他的女友梅兰妮亚，她也太棒了。嗨，嗨，我是梅兰妮亚。”狂热的吹捧、崇拜、偶像化。人类很容易巴结富有和权势的人。但事实证明，这只是我们心理的一面。在另一面，则是完全不同的东西。我们中的许多人恨富人，因为他们富有。我们希望看到掌权者从他们的基座上倒台。
We enjoy seeing the glamorous fall and fail. The lure of celebrity tours is rivaled only by the popularity of tabloid magazines, detailing the rehab trips and broken marriages of those same celebrities. If a monochist enthralled by pomp and power sits on one of our shoulders, a vengeful populous sits on the other, a populous suspicious of power distrustful of the wealthy, eager to have the high-end mighty pulled off their pedestals. The thin line between adoring the rich and powerful and marching them to the guillotine, this week on Hidden Brain. On a pre-dawn morning, a high-stalker in Paris. Breaking news this morning, and Kim Kardashian robbed at gunpoint in Paris late last night by
我们喜欢看到光鲜亮丽的人陨落和失败。名人游览的吸引力，唯有那些详细报道这些名人去戒毒所和婚姻破裂的八卦杂志的受欢迎程度可以与之媲美。如果一个沉迷于排场和权力的保皇派坐在我们的一个肩膀上，那么一个复仇的平民主义者就坐在另一个肩膀上——一个对权力保持警惕、对富人充满不信任、急切地想把高高在上和大权在握的人从神坛上拉下来的平民主义者。崇拜富有和权势与将他们押上断头台之间只有一线之隔。本周《隐藏的大脑》。在一个黎明前的早晨，巴黎发生了一起重大尾随事件。“今晨突发新闻，金·卡戴珊昨晚深夜在巴黎遭遇持枪抢劫，
five men dressed as police officers. The robbers made off not only with Kim case, 20-carat, emerald-cut diamond engagement ring, but other jewels and cash totaling more than $10 million. The news media was sympathetic to Kim's ordeal. A source close to Kim tells ET, the mother of two is still very, very shaken up. Quote, she thought she was going to die. They put a gun to her head while they were searching the apartment. She was crying begging them for her life.
五名打扮成警察的男子作案。”劫匪不仅抢走了金的20克拉祖母绿切割钻石订婚戒指，还抢走了其他珠宝和现金，总计超过1000万美元。新闻媒体对金遭遇的磨难表示同情。“一位接近金的消息人士告诉《今夜娱乐》，这位两个孩子的母亲仍然非常、非常震惊。她说：‘她以为自己要死了。他们把枪抵在她的头上，同时搜查公寓。她一直在哭，乞求他们饶她一命。’”
The sympathy didn't last long, especially on social media. Andrea McDonald is a communications professor who's interested in celebrity culture. There's a tweet here from the House of WTF that says, quote, Kim Kardashian was held at gunpoint in a Paris hotel. Man will be charged with not pulling the trigger and saving humanity from mediocrity. Or this post. After years of desperation, Kim Kardashian finally
这种同情并没有持续多久，尤其是在社交媒体上。安德丽娅·麦克唐纳是一位对名人文化感兴趣的传播学教授。“‘WTF之屋’发了一条推文说：‘金·卡戴珊在巴黎的一家酒店里被人持枪劫持。应当起诉那个没有扣动扳机、从而没能把人类从平庸中拯救出来的歹徒。’或者这条帖子：‘经过多年的绝望，金·卡戴珊今天终于有了上新闻的理由。’”还有其他尖酸刻薄的评论。也许金是自导自演了一场抢劫来炒作。也许她自导自演是为了好消失去做更多整形手术。
has a reason to be in the news today. There were other snarky comments. Maybe Kim faked the robbery as a publicity stunt. Maybe she faked it so she could disappear for more plastic surgery. Where was the love, the outpouring of concern from Kim's millions of fans? Why, after a brutal robbery, did people turn on her? Andrea has a theory. Kim Kardashian is someone who has made her whole living out of being famous and employing her fame to make money and really flaunting her success and wealth in various ways.
那种爱在哪里？金的数百万粉丝倾注的关怀在哪里？为什么在遭遇残酷抢劫后，人们却调转枪口对付她？安德丽娅有一个理论。金·卡戴珊整个人生都是靠出名以及利用名气赚钱，并且真的在通过各种方式炫耀她的成功和财富。
And so when that wealth is quite literally attacked in a very confrontational and personal way. Our potential empathy for her, even if we are fans of hers, may be lacking there because of our own potential envy or distaste for some of her personal presentation of wealth. In other words, as much as many of us like seeing the rich and luxurious world of Kim, we don't like the idea that she's rubbing it in our faces. And so we don't mind when she's taken down a few notches. We do the same with our political leaders.
因此，当这种财富在一种非常对抗性和个人化的方式中字面意义上受到攻击时。我们对她的潜在同情，即使我们是她的粉丝，也可能会因为我们自己潜在的嫉妒或对她某些个人财富展示的反感而有所缺失。换句话说，尽管我们许多人喜欢看金那富有而奢华的世界，但我们不喜欢她把这一切擦到我们脸上的想法。因此，当她受到一些打击时，我们并不介意。我们对政治领袖也是如此。
We adore the pomp and circumstance associated with high office, but we pounce at the slightest gaff. Vice President Dan Quayle was all but drawn and quartered when he urged a little boy to add an E to the spelling of the word potato. And Texas Governor Rick Perry suffered a moment of forgetfulness during the presidential debate. I would do away with the education, the commerce. And let's see, I can't.
我们崇拜与高位相关的浮华和礼节，但我们会在哪怕最轻微的失言时扑上去。副总统丹·奎尔敦促一个小男孩在单词“potato”的拼写中加一个E时，几乎遭到了五马分尸的严厉抨击。而得克萨斯州长里克·佩里在总统辩论中经历了一个健忘的时刻。“我会废除教育部、商务部，然后……让我想想，我想不起来了。”
That was the end of Rick Perry's role in the National Spotlight. At least until President-elect Donald Trump chose him to leave the department he couldn't remember. Energy. Governor Howard Deans 2004 campaign for President came to a crashing halt when he ended a televised speech with slightly too much enthusiasm. We're going to South Carolina and Oklahoma and Arizona and North Dakota and New Mexico. We're going to California and Texas and New York. We're going to South Dakota and Oregon and Washington and New York, and we're going to South Dakota, and Oregon, and Washington, and Michigan!
那是里克·佩里在全国聚光灯下角色的终结。至少直到当选总统唐纳德·特朗普选择他去领导那个他记不起来的部门——能源部。州长霍华德·迪恩2004年的总统竞选在他在电视演讲结束时表现出稍微过多的热情时戛然而止。“我们要去南卡罗来纳州、俄克拉荷马州、亚利桑那州、北达科他州和新墨西哥州！我们要去加利福尼亚州、得克萨斯州和纽约州！我们要去南达科他州、俄勒冈州、华盛顿州和纽约州，我们要去南达科他州、俄勒冈州、华盛顿州和密歇根州！”
And then we're going to watch it at E.C. and take back the White House! Yeah! Goodbye, Mr. Dean. You get the point. We can adore our leaders one moment and skewer them the next. Not long ago, I was watching all the way, a wonderful movie about Lyndon B. Johnson, starring actor Brian Kranzsten. There's one scene that stayed with me.
“然后我们要去华盛顿特区，夺回白宫！耶！”再见，迪恩先生。你懂的。我们可以在这一秒崇拜我们的领袖，下一秒就尖刻地批评他们。不久前，我一直在观看《全盘行动》，这是一部关于林登·B·约翰逊的精彩电影，由演员布莱恩·科兰斯顿主演。有一个场景深深留在了我心中。
It sums up the contradictory feelings humans have toward people in power. LBJ has just been elected president. He walks through an enduring crowd, and he says this to himself. faces will be watching me. Wait, and one first moment of weakness. And then they will gut me like a deer. It's not a bad analogy, given that so much of our psychology was formed in the ancient past, when humans lived in small, nomadic tribes of hunter-gatherers. Some researchers believe the roots of our love-hate relationship with power lie in this evolutionary history. If we look carefully, we can still find evidence for it today in the forest of Tanzania.
它总结了人类对掌权者矛盾的情感。LBJ刚刚当选总统。他走过密集的人群，对自己这样说：“成千上万双眼睛在看着我。等着吧，只要有一个软弱的时刻。然后他们就会像剖鹿一样把我开膛破肚。”考虑到我们的许多心理是在远古时期形成的——当时人类生活在由狩猎采集者组成的小型游牧部落中，这个比喻并不过分。一些研究人员认为，我们对权力的爱恨交织关系的根源就在于这种进化史。如果我们仔细观察，今天仍然可以在坦桑尼亚的森林中找到证据。
Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. To understand the contradictory relationship that humans have with power, we need to go back in time, way back, to prehistory, to our evolutionary past. One way to do this is to observe the behavior of a close relative, the chimpanzee. As a young woman, the evolutionary anthropologist and pucy walked deep into the Tanzanian forest. She was there as a student assistant to the great primatologist, Jane Goodall. Anne's job was to observe and record chimpanzee behavior in the wild.
请继续收听。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。要理解人类与权力之间矛盾的关系，我们需要回到过去，追溯到史前时期，回到我们的进化过去。方法之一就是观察我们的近亲黑猩猩的行为。作为一个年轻女性，进化人类学家安·普西深入坦桑尼亚的森林。她作为伟大灵长类动物学家简·古道尔的学生助手来到这里。安的工作是观察和记录野外黑猩猩的行为。
Sometimes she'd watch the chimps at a feeding location loaded with bananas, other times she'd simply trail them. And following them around was pretty tough because it's, as I said, a rugged place and so you're going up and down, you're crawling through vines, the paths, if there are paths that the chimps walk on are small and you often have to scramble through the vegetation. And if they didn't want to be followed, they could very easily lose you. Over time, Anne began to understand how the chimps engaged with each other. Chimps society is very male-dom dominated. The headhunt show is the alpha male.
有时她会在堆满香蕉的喂食地点观察黑猩猩，有时她只是尾随它们。跟着它们到处跑相当艰难，因为正如我所说，那是一个崎岖不地方，所以你要上上下下，你要艰难地穿过藤蔓，如果黑猩猩走的路有路的话也是很小的，你经常得在植被中艰难爬行。如果它们不想被跟踪，它们很容易就能把你甩掉。随着时间推移，安开始了解黑猩猩是如何彼此交往的。黑猩猩社会是高度雄性统治的。掌权的老大就是阿尔法雄鹿（阿尔法雄性）。
He's often the center of attention. The other males will groom him. He's probably groomed more by than other males are. And the same, the females pay particular attention to the alpha male as well, partly because they get chased around by him more. So that there's certainly probably a benefit to individuals from having a good relationship with the alpha male from their own point of view of safety
他往往是注意力的中心。其他雄性会给他理毛。他接受理毛的次数可能比其他雄性更多。同样，雌性也非常关注阿尔法雄性，部分原因在于她们经常被他追着跑。因此，对个体来说，与阿尔法雄性保持良好关系显然可能带来好处，从他们自身对安全感以及可能从他那里获得的支援的角度来看。通常，年轻的雄性似乎在崇拜阿尔法。我观察到的一些雄性，尤其是其中一个，总是跟在阿尔法雄性后面。阿尔法雄性会做一个冲锋展示，而我正在观察的小雄性就会跟在他后面冲锋，并踢同一棵树的树根。
and maybe support that they may gain from him. Often, the younger males appear to idolize the alpha. Some of the males I watched, especially one in particular, just follow the alpha male around. And he, the alpha male would do a charging display, and the little male I was watching would sort of charge long behind him and kick the same buttress of the tree. But the relationship between the alpha and others in the group is more complicated than it might first seem.
但阿尔法与群体中其他成员之间的关系比乍看起来要复杂得多。克里斯·博姆是一位文化人类学家，他也曾与简·古道尔一起工作，观察黑猩猩。基本上，如果你观察单个黑猩猩以及它们在长辈面前的表现，就会发现这是相当矛盾的。每当阿尔法雄性威吓其他黑猩猩时，你都能看到这种矛盾心理。他基本上像疯了一样。他到处跑。他竖起所有的毛发让自己看起来尽可能大，连根拔起树木并扔掉，捡起巨石并在空中挥舞，在藤蔓上气势汹汹地荡来荡去，四处狂奔，并攻击任何没有通过匆忙爬上树来表现出敬意的群体成员。
Christopher Bohm is a cultural anthropologist who also worked with Jane Goodall observing the chimps. Basically, if you look at the individual chimpanzees and how they behave around their superiors, it's rather ambivalent. You can see the sembivalence each time the alpha male intimidates the other chimps. He basically goes crazy. He runs around. He writes all of his hair to look as big as possible. Uproots, trees, and throws them, picks up boulders, heaves them in the air, swings aggressively on finds, races around, and attacks any member of the group that doesn't show deference by going up a tree in a hurry.
克里斯在观察黑猩猩时觉得有趣的是接下来发生的事。当它们冲上树时，它们在尖叫，这是一种恐惧的发声，它告诉阿尔法雄性“我怕你”，所以这也是一种敬意。但当它们到达树顶时，它们就会停止尖叫，并发出另一种叫声，叫做“墙吠”。而“墙吠”听起来有点像这样：噢，但声音要大得多。而这种“墙吠”叫声是一种蔑视和敌意。因此，一旦它们到达树顶，并且知道对方不会费心上来惩罚它们时，它们就开始对他狂吠。
What Chris found interesting as he watched the chimps is what happened next. As they race up the trees, they are screaming, which is a fear of vocalizations, which tells the alpha male I'm scared of you, so it's also deference. But as they get up to the top of the tree, they then stop screaming and they give another call called the wall bark. And a wall sounds something like this, law, but ever so much louder. And the wall call is one of defiance and hostility. And so once they're up in the tree tops and they know he isn't going to take the trouble
这告诉他以及我，它们不喜欢他刚才做的事，因为他基本上压制并吓唬了它们，迫使它们在原本更愿意在地面上觅食等的时候逃上一棵树。因此，就矛盾心理而言，一旦你对这个物种很熟悉，对阿尔法雄性的政治矛盾心理就很容易辨认。换句话说，交织在奉承和顺从之中的，是反抗和叛逆的丝线。早期人类似乎也具备这种特征。
to come up and punish them, they all start whying at him. And this tells him and me that they don't like what he just did, because he's basically dominated and frightened them and forced them to run up a tree when they'd rather be on the ground feeding and so on. So, in terms of ambivalence, political ambivalence toward the alpha male is pretty easy to identify once you know the species well. In other words, woven into the fabric of adulation and submission are strands of defiance and rebellion. Early humans seem to share this trait.
克里斯研究了几乎与外界没有接触、其生活几千年来几乎没有改变的游牧狩猎采集部落。他再次发现的是对掌权者的深刻矛盾心理。以狩猎采集部落中最具权力的成员之一——娴熟的猎人为例。人们喜欢这家伙，但只要他试图将这些肉转化为权力，也就是把肉据为己有并分给他的亲信，以此来发展权力。
Chris has studied nomadic hunter-gatherer tribes who have had almost no contact with the outside world and whose lives have changed little over thousands of years. What he found again was a deep ambivalence about the powerful. Take for example one of the most powerful members of a hunter-gatherer tribe, the skilled hunter. And people love this guy, but the minute he tries to turn that meat into power, that is to keep the meat for himself and give it to his cronies and develop power that way, it to his cronies and develop power that way. The group will treat him with extreme discuracy, they may criticize him. If it gets too bad, they may ostracize him. If it really gets too bad, and the guy is a real despot and is trying to basically take other people's
群体就会以极度不赞成的态度对待他，他们可能会批评他。如果情况变得太糟，他们可能会排挤他。如果真的变得太糟，这家伙成了一个真正的暴君，并试图剥夺其他人的自主权，他们就会杀了他。伟大的猎人受到钦佩和尊崇，但如果他过于自大，他很快就会被拉下马。在他的书《森林中的等级制度》中，克里斯得出结论，早期人类社会的特点是显著的平等主义。他断言，民主的根源不在于《美国独立宣言》，甚至不在古希腊。它们编织在人类的DNA中。
autonomy away, they'll kill him. The great hunter is admired and revered, but if he becomes too big for his boots, he's quickly taken down. In his book, Hierarchy in the Forest, Chris concluded that early human society was marked by a remarkably egalitarianism. The roots of democracy he concluded weren't in the American Declaration of Independence or even in ancient Greece. They're woven into the DNA of human beings.
实际上，人类在某种程度上倾向于仰望那些富有和有权势的人，同时也倾向于对他们在道德上进行特殊的审查。再说一次，如果你有一个领袖，并且你密切注视着他不让他的权力过度发展，那种审查是非常重要的。我们对权力的矛盾态度在富有和权势的人眼里并不是秘密。这也是幕僚们如此努力地让领袖和名人们显得接地气和谦逊的原因之一。里根总统经常被拍到穿着牛仔裤和法兰绒衬衫在牧场劈柴或给马装鞍。
Really, humans are somehow disposed to look up to those who are rich and powerful, and also to subject them to special scrutiny morally. And again, if you have a leader and you're watching out carefully that he doesn't overdevelop his power, that kind of scrutiny is very important. Our contradictory attitudes about power aren't lost on the rich and powerful. It's one reason handlers work so hard to make leaders and celebrities look down to earth and humble. President Reagan was often shown in jeans and flannel shirt cutting wood on his ranch
“我以前常骑马，而且只是淡化……我忘了，在勒紧肚带之前……”肯尼迪一家为了好玩去玩滑水，并且记得带上媒体同行。“这是在路易斯湾海亚纳的一次家庭郊游，一项属于肯尼迪家族的运动。总统在慈父般的祝福下，由他的兄弟们和一大群孩子的陪伴下，在水上度过了一天，放松了华盛顿的烦恼。”受人爱戴的领袖可不是唯一学会这招的人。2011年，《Vogue》杂志发表了一篇关于阿斯玛·阿萨德和她的丈夫巴沙尔的吹捧文章。
or saddling up his horses. That used to ride and would just play down the m and I forget and girth up before I remember. The Kennedys went water skiing for fun and remember to bring the media along. It's a family outing in Louis Bay, Hianna, a sport for the Kennedays. The president, accompanied by his kind of a blessing father, his brothers, and a full complement of children, relaxes from the cares of Washington with a day on the water. Beloved leaders are the only ones who have learned this trick. In 2011, Vogue ran a puff piece about Asma Alassad and her husband Bashar.
她是沙漠中的玫瑰。他们一起是美丽、接地气的夫妇，深深致力于赋予叙利亚公民和叙利亚公民社会权力。两年后，阿萨德政权对自己的子民使用了化学武器。或者考虑这一点。几十年前，各大国际报纸报道了一位知名领袖的家庭生活。读者了解到，他位于巴伐利亚隐居处的内部空间被刷成了各种色调的绿色。他的卧室里挂着他母亲的画像。
She was the rose in the desert. Together they were the beautiful, down-to-earth couple deeply committed to empowering citizens in Syrian civil society. Two years later the Assad regime used chemical weapons on its own people. Or consider this. Decades earlier, various international newspapers wrote about the domestic life of a well-known leader. Readers learned the interior spaces of his Bavarian retreat were painted in various shades of green. There was a portrait of his mother in his bedroom.
他早餐吃牛奶、面包、蜂蜜、燕麦片和奶酪。他们谈论他的素食主义。他们谈论他的狗以及他有多爱他的狗，他的狗有多爱他。他们谈论他是多么喜欢孩子。这个人就是阿道夫·希特勒。在其著作《家中的希特勒》中，斯皮纳·斯特拉蒂加科斯探讨了纳粹宣传机器如何将希特勒塑造为一个谦逊的、与自然融为一体的人民之子的形象。1937年，《纽约时报杂志》刊登了对希特勒隐居山区、思考国家命运的同情性一瞥。
He breakfasted on milk, bread, honey, oatmeal, and cheese. They talk about his vegetarianism. They talk about his dogs and how much he loves his dogs and his dogs love him. They talk about how much he loves children. The man was Edal Hitler. In her book, Hitler at Home, the Spina Stratigacos explores how the Nazi propaganda machine
令人震惊的是，在这篇1937年的《纽约时报》文章之后，1939年8月20日，《纽约时报》再次出现了一篇绝对的吹捧文章，而且那篇完全没有一点批判性。它是由一位我未能查明身份的女性撰写的，她谈到了希特勒喜欢醋栗派以及他桌上的西红柿是多么美味。
created an image of Hitler as a humble man of the people at ease in nature. In 1937, the New York Times magazine featured a sympathetic glimpse of Hitler living in the mountains, thinking about the destiny of his nation. Shockingly, after this 1937 New York Times article, there is an absolute puff piece that appears on August 20, 1939 in the New York Times again, and that one has absolutely no critical edge to it. It is by a woman who I haven't been able to identify, who talks about the fact that Hitler loves Gooseberry Pie and how wonderful the tomatoes are on his table.
而这篇文章发表的时间，你知道的，距离希特勒入侵波兰不到两周。醋栗派、滑水肯尼迪的照片、像牛仔一样梳理马匹的总统，这些图像所做的是在传达：别担心，我可能很有权势，但我并没有与你们脱节。我们仍然有联系。我们是一样的。距离巴伐利亚阿尔卑斯山数千英里之遥，好莱坞的游客们正在平衡我们对富有和有权势的人所抱有的双重冲动。
And it appears, you know, just less than two weeks before Hitler invades Poland. Gooseberry Pie, a photo of a water skiing Kennedy, a president grooming his horses like a cowboy, what these images do is say, don't worry, I may be powerful, but I haven't lost touch with you. We're still connected. We're the same. Thousands of miles from the Bavarian Alps, tourists in Hollywood are balancing the twin impulses we have toward
当游览穿过好莱坞山时，它停了下来，一个新的停靠点。“不管你恨不恨新总统，或者你爱不爱他，我只想告诉你这一点，右手边这就是他的房子。这就是唐纳德·J·特朗普在贝弗利山庄的冬宫，就在右手边，那栋房子。我们把游泳池拍下来吧。那是最小的游泳池。后面是仆人的住所。”唐纳德·特朗普的当选点燃了我们对富有和权势之人的矛盾情感。
the rich and powerful. As the tour winds through the Hollywood hills, it comes to a stop, a new one. And whether you hit the new president or you love him, I can just tell you this, this is his house on the right hand side. This is Donald J. Trump's winter estate here in Beverly Hills right here on the right hand side, the house there. And we're going to pop the pools right there. It's the tiniest little pool. And here's the servants' quarters back here. Donald Trump's election has ignited the contradictory feelings we have toward the rich and powerful.
在批评者眼里，唐纳德·特朗普打破了许多领导人树立的谦逊先例。他又富有，又有权势，又出名，而且他毫不掩饰地炫耀这一点。用进化人类学的语言来说，他是部落里好大喜功的猎人。但在他的支持者看来，他非常像一个平民，一个承诺创造公平竞争环境的人，一个平民主义者。用进化人类学的语言来说，他是那个发誓要分享肉食的熟练猎人。你可以确信这一点。当闪光灯亮起、车队驶过时，将会有无数崇拜的微笑和隐藏的匕首。
To his critics, Donald Trump has broken with the precedent of modesty set by many leaders. He's rich, he's powerful, he's famous, and he flaunts it. In the language of evolutionary anthropology, he is the boastful hunter in the tribe. But to his supporters, he's very much a man of the people, someone who's promised to level the playing field, a populist. In the language of evolutionary anthropology, he's the skilled hunter who vows to share the meat. You can be sure of this. As the cameras flash and the motorcades go by, there will be lots of adoring smiles and
《隐藏的大脑》由Hidden Brain Media制作。Midroa Media是我们独家的广告销售合作伙伴。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、劳拉·夸雷尔、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。我们本周的无名英雄是我们前制片人珍妮·施密特。珍妮在《隐藏的大脑》的发展中发挥了至关重要的作用。她热爱优美的文字，这很合情合理，因为她本人就是一个优秀的作家。你听到的在我们节目中展开的许多故事，
conceal daggers. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Midroa Media is our exclusive advertising sales partner. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Laura Quarell, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero this week is our former producer, Jenny Schmidt. Jenny played an essential role in the development of Hidden Brain. She loves beautiful writing, which makes sense, because she is herself a beautiful writer. Many of the stories
包括今天的节目，都带有她标志性写作风格的印记。我们非常高兴能有机会与她合作并向她学习。谢谢你，珍妮。想了解更多关于《隐藏的大脑》的信息，你可以在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们。在hiddenbrain.org上查找关于我们的更多信息。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。下周见。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
that you've heard unfold on our show, including today's episode, bear the mark of her signature writing style. We're so glad to have had the chance to work with her and learn from her. Thank you, Jenny. For more Hidden Brain, you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter. Find more information about us at hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantum. See you next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您在我们的节目中听到的那些故事，包括今天的节目，都带有她标志性的写作风格。我们非常高兴有机会与她合作并向她学习。谢谢你，Jenny。想收听更多 HiddenBrain 节目，您可以在 Facebook 和 Twitter 上关注我们。请访问 hiddenbrain.org 了解我们的更多信息。我是 Shankar Vedantum。下周见。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。